you
as promised this is part 2 of the Q&A
video you guys asked a lot of questions
so let's jump right in
a lot of you want to know a little bit
more about my education I attended
Stanford University in Birmingham
Alabama
that's Samford not Stanford I'm not that
smart where I studied broadcast and
minored in film production I graduated
with a bachelor's degree in journalism
and mass communication in 2015 where do
you live
right now I live in Dallas Texas believe
it or not not all of us sound like
Cowboys I've also lived in New York Ohio
New Jersey and Connecticut are you alone
or do you have a team I do all of the
actual video making myself by which I
mean writing the script recording and
editing the audio and animating the
video itself however I do have a few
very helpful volunteer researchers whose
work is consistently excellent big
shout-out to the thought squad is
mayonnaise and instrument no and neither
is horseradish how do you come up with
topics well it depends most of the time
a question will just pop into my head
and I'll pursue the topic it's helpful
to be genuinely interested in the world
around us if I'm having trouble thinking
of a topic I'll typically look around
for new discoveries in astronomy as I
think space is a very exciting topic
Wendover productions asked how is it
possible that you real-life lore and
royal ocean film society all know each
other personally and all became
successful youtubers I'll start by
saying I'm very flattered for being
recognized by such a quality youtuber
and if any of you haven't seen one
different videos I encourage you to
check out his channel as for the
question Jo from real life lore andrew
from royal ocean film society and i have
been good friends for a number of years
we all get together once a week with
some other friends to watch and discuss
a film i think our success has come
partly from being around to support each
other and partly from surrounding
ourselves with good company there's a
quote I like that says if you're the
smartest person in the room find a
different room what's with the cow you
know it was kind of an accident I first
used the cow in one of my early videos
about the strangest things to fall from
the sky some people commented that they
liked him so I used him again in another
video and the rest is history he's so
much a part of the channel now that he's
even on my business cards speaking of
the cow he doesn't have a name
leave your vote in the comments for what
we should name our favorite cow can we
see your face I get asked this a lot and
I don't really know why
I mean I'm gorgeous of course but that's
not something I would have thought
people would find so important anyway
I'll be going to playlist live and
VidCon this year so I'm sure I'll be in
some photos or video clips for you all
to see and make sure to come find me if
you'll be there too a lot of people have
asked how I make my videos now I'm not
going to say I uploaded a video
specifically outlining how I make my
videos but I uploaded a video
specifically outlining how I make my
videos but I'll go ahead and reiterate
here because I like you guys
once I've written my script I start by
recording my audio using a zoom h5 I sit
in my closet because it's quiet and I
don't have a studio once my audio is
recorded I'll put it in Adobe Premiere
to cut out all the breaths pauses and
mistakes now Premiere isn't specifically
designed to edit audio but I'm very
familiar with it so I use it if you want
to edit your own audio I recommend
something like Adobe Audition
I export my audio as a WAV file and
import it into after-effects from there
I started a long process of animating
which leads to another question how long
does it take to make a video well it
varies depending on the topic but a
rough estimate is about 15 to 20 hours
from concept to final export what made
you want to start second thought believe
it or not I had a tutorial channel way
back in the early days of YouTube stuff
like how to solve a Rubik's Cube and
little editing tricks of course I had no
idea what I was doing but it was fun
fast forward to about a year ago Joe
from real-life lore and I decided we
both wanted to try again
so we made our channels really it was
because we're both interested in
different aspects of the world around us
and we wanted to share our curiosity
with like-minded people who are your
favorite youtubers of course on the top
of my list a real life lore and Royal
Ocean Film Society then there's wind
over productions Kurt's Kazakh CGP Grey
real engineering alternate history hub
okay there are a lot basically if they
make quality educational videos I like
them other than that I'm a big Pokemon
fan so shady Penguin has to be on the
list did you expect your channel to grow
so quickly absolutely not it came as a
huge surprise I had about 8,000
subscribers before I uploaded my NASA
budget video then I woke up to 25,000
subscribers the following morning it
makes me happy to be able to share
interesting topics with so many people
have you ever thought about selling
merchandise or doing a fan meetup
actually yes those are both on the list
of things I'd like to do in the near
future
if you're interested in either of these
things let me know in the comments so I
can gauge community interest what kind
of books do you read I'm a big fan of
historical nonfiction right now I'm
reading the guns of August which is a
fantastic account of the months leading
up to World War one in today's society
it's very easy to get bogged down with
useless information so it's good to work
through a full book when you have the
time do you do YouTube full time and if
so what did you do before YouTube yes I
make my living off youtube now before I
started my channel I worked in the
camera department at Best Buy which is a
big electronics chain if you're not
familiar the recent YouTube advertising
debacle has affected many full-time
youtubers myself included so if you'd
like to help keep second thought afloat
consider supporting the channel on
patreon one especially thoughtful
comment said how do you think this
opportunity has changed your life where
do you see yourself going forward any
plans for expanding the series types or
staff of the channel while I don't want
to get all sentimental here the
opportunity to pursue making educational
videos for a living is a dream come true
I was very unhappy at my old job and
starting a youtube channel was one of
the best decisions I've ever made as for
my career moving forward I'd like to
continue doing YouTube for as long as I
can and hopefully work with lots of
other great creators along the way as of
right now I don't have any plans to
bring on any official staff especially
with the advertising situation that
being said I'm always open to community
contributions such as research subtitles
and original music and I've saved the
most important question for last
does pineapple belong on Pizza this
question has a long island history and
I'm here to settle it once and for all
the answer is thanks again to everyone
who submitted questions hopefully this
video has answered most of them if not
feel free to ask whatever questions you
have left in the comments below and I'll
try my best to answer them you people
make second thought the amazing family
that it is and for that I thank you
thanks for watching and I'll see you at
500,000
you